hi youtube this is much from British
Council I've just been in the BBC debate
on the financial crisis it's been very
interesting very exciting quite a tough
discussion but one thing that's on my
mind after this discussion after hearing
the discussion is that several of the
people on stage said that the current
financial crisis is not due to
individuals or companies doing something
wrong it's actually a systemically so
it's a system and wrong now what a
wondering is once we solve the crisis
touch wood and things go well again I
wonder what they're also going to say
well it's not because of us that we're
making this much money it's because of
the system so I think the debate show
that there's a huge lack of taking any
responsibility we can't probably make
the banks and companies responsible for
everything that has gone wrong but if
they don't take any responsibility how
are we going to trust them again thank
you very much